the government held true to their word
this afternoon and they refused to
discuss pay with me in the room this
afternoon
so is part of you wondering why they
held those talks in the first place
because you made it very clear the pay
had to be on the table before you would
go along and talk look if I have made it
very clear that if they want to avert
the strike on Thursday and on the 20th
of December and moving forward we needed
to get into a room with myself to
discuss pay or with conciliation through
aircast
um I went into that room today with
hopes obviously and came out with not
one single Brown Penny and for our
nursing the hopes in a preparation to
compromise a little perhaps I said let's
open the discussions today let's open
the negotiations but there's no point in
me getting into that because the
Secretary of State made it very clear
the books were closed they've accepted
prb we haven't
um our nursing staff haven't the largest
mandate that any Trade union has had in
a very long time and he refused to
listen BRB the pay review body which
which the government says is responsible
for deciding the the size of the rise it
is and we have provided evidence year on
year to the peer review body that
evidence gets ignored
um and you know let's be clear the pay
review body is not independent the pay
review body remit is set by government
and those letters are a matter of record
on their website on what they say they
tell the prb at their pay round they
tell them basically what they should be
providing and then the system the
organizations that employ our nurses
were told last this year to budget for
three percent and Kels reprise what does
prb offer three percent so we are we are
going to round in circles I did a lot of
talking reminding the Secretary of State
about the crisis that we are in and it
was for me
um I think he showed total belligerence
to the nursing profession this afternoon
he closed his books and they walked away
and they've turned their back on our
nursing profession well you see I mean
it's a strong word belligerence what did
he say what precisely did he discuss how
long were you in there for we were in
for about half an hour right so and
Secretary of State I mean how did he
display that belligerence I think what
I've said is that I did most of the
talking
um and there was very little talking
coming from the other side of the table
except to keep repeating to me that he
has accepted the independent peer review
body position for this year and there
will be no more money put in the on the
table of course he he restated
um the the economic position of the
country he rested it um inflation and we
kept going round the circle
um and talking about the same things
every time I brought the Secretary of
State back to say please we need to
address pay if we were to avert this
this strike happening on Thursday I need
to have a discussion with you about pay
um and that was not forthcoming does
that not cut any ice with the uou
members that that economic argument
about inflation the state of the
nation's fine ounces of course it does
of course it does but let's not forget
that nurses pay has dropped by 20 in the
last decade in fact what they're looking
for is pay restoration that money back
into their pockets so that they can live
um their lives as well and be actually
able to look after their children pay
their utility bills and be able to pay
transport to get to their work they're
not asking for their pockets to be lined
with gold never have and never will
they're not a greedy profession I keep
saying it but we need to have pay
addressed for those nurses they are
living beneath the bread line they can
no longer afford to continue to work in
our profession and I think that's a sad
indictment those people are leaving in
droves to find jobs elsewhere elsewhere
and we cannot afford to lose one single
nurse out of our profession nor can our
patients afford to lose them and just in
terms of what happens this week we know
that so many of your members if when
they go on strike this week are going to
do so with a heavy heart because of the
very nature of their core calling but do
you think that belligerence you
described there from the secretary of
state will stiffen resolve amongst the
membership
I think our nursing staff are in such a
place and I never thought in all of my
nursing career 43 years now that and and
in the 106 year history of this great
college that we would have the strength
of mandate for strike action amongst our
profession in fact if you look at the
history of our College the majority of
our nurses all joined the college
because we had a no strike position
within the college and now we're finding
the strongest mandate ever so I think
that tells its own story our profession
is struggling big time they're
struggling to look after their patients
when they come out at night and come off
shift they are worrying about the work
that the and the care that they've left
on done and then they get up worrying
about what's going to face in the next
day with the 50 000 vacant posts that
are within the system in England alone
and the same throughout the other
countries so it's no way to treat the
profession no way to treat patients
those 7.2 million people languishing on
waiting lists want to treat that we want
to treat and they'll not be treated
unless we address the issues and and
with a strike those waiting lists can
only get a bit longer so it seems the
15th this Thursday is baked in given
what happened this evening any hope
though to avert the 20th and maybe
subsequent strikes look as a nurse I
always live and hope and our nursing
staff will live in Hope but we've been
left out in the cold left out in the
cold by the Secretary of State and where
do our nurses want to be on the 15th and
the 20th they want to be in their
hospitals in their communities and in
the houses of our patients caring for
our patients we never set out to do what
we've done but unless we have the issues
of pay addressed we are going to
continue to drain nurses out of our
profession and we're going to continue
with the crisis and the Health Service
and you're going to continue to take
industrial action could that industrial
election then continue into the new year
and could you join it up with other
members of you unions other workers
represented within the Health Service no
we've no plans to join up with any other
Union
um my mandate is from our nursing staff
over 320 000 nurses took part in this
ballot that's a very significant group
of people so my concentration and Royal
colleges concentration is on those
nurses and we'll continue to do that
you've asked me could it continue on the
saddest thing after today's meeting I
think it will and what about any more
talks nothing in the pipeline well
certainly that wasn't the tone of the
meeting today but again I would say to
the Secretary of State of his listening
this evening my door is wide open for
serious talks about pay if he doesn't
want to have those with me face to face
and on a one-to-one let's go through
conciliation but he has to move but just
to be clear about that if you're calling
for conciliation and serious talks about
pay you've got an offer out there you
are prepared to negotiate on that to
come down a bit I have said time and
time again let's get to the table and
negotiate face to face not on the
airwaves we won't do that
um but today was an opportunity that the
secretary of state has significantly
missed